Now that we've found out how many gallons of cleaning solution Grant's going to
buy, we can look back to our equations that dealt with the amount that cleaning
solution would cost for him, depending on which brand he decided to go with. And
each do a little bit of variable switch up though. To get back in the paradigm
that these equations were written in, I'll remind you of what each of the
variables stood for, x here stood for the number of solution that Grant would
buy, and y was equal to the total cost of Grant's order, taking into account
both the solution that he bought in the rush order fee for each company. Setting
up our coordinate plane with a scale of 10 on the x axis and 100 on the y axis,
I'm going to graph these 3 lines again. To make this graph easier for you to
read and understand, I've color coded the lines again just like we did before,
and then written their corresponding equations in the proper colors. We've
talked a ton in the past about how we can find values of variables that satisfy
equations but we can also do this graphically. Think for a second, if I wanted
to find out how much 75 gallons of solution will cost for each brand that Grant
might buy from, what extra line should I add to this graph? Please write the
equation for that new line in this box.